How effectively is the Chicago statement on,
on how effectively is the Chicago statement being disseminated?
How rapidly our universities signing up or,
or,
um,
you signed on early in this whole crisis,
uh,
Purdue,
they're about 10 or 15 that have,
that have endorsed it or something like it.
Uh,
it's not enough to just endorse something,
but if you have leadership that is committed to creating an open platform in
which people can disagree.
Um,
and,
and um,
one tense,
very encouraging.
I've been invited by number of university presidents to come speak.
We have all kinds of innovations to heterodox academy to foster a more inclusive
climate in which people can actually engage with difference.
There's a lot of interests.
So I think the university leaders were very slow to react.
They didn't want to alienate certain factions of students,
but they're almost all these noble people,
they're almost all liberal left,
not a liberal.
They're horrified by what's going on.
They know they're sitting a top of a powder keg.
They don't want things to blow up in their face has happened at Evergreen.
So this brings us to our,
our,
another product.
The one that we're most excited by.
Uh,
so we just went online,
uh,
actually,
today,
uh,
it's called the open mind platform.
If you go to open mind a platform.org,
you can find we've developed an APP.
We have a whole library of readings and videos.
We do have an APP that guides you through.
We don't just say here's how to engage with different viewpoints.
We start by saying,
why is it good and we make the case that you need this.
Everybody needs this.
And to,
um,
we remind people that we're all basically self righteous hypocrites.
We have quotes from wisdom traditions around the world and we've all heard this.
So just a little bit of,
you know,
you can call it emotional manipulation if you like,
but just get people into a mindset in which they're willing to say,
oh yeah,
whoa.
You know,
calm down.
We're all,
we're all uh,
and too self righteous here.
And then we,
then we teach them some psychology,
um,
about motivated reasoning.
And only then do we teach them to engage with views that are not their own.
So we've already run this in about 15 or 20 classes.
Um,
the results so far look promising that at the end of it,
the measures showed that students are more open to other ideas.
So the open mind platform we think is a tool that we think a lot of universities
are going to adopt their,
there's a lot of interest in it.
And if there's leadership,
if the professors generally do support viewpoint diversity and open inquiry,
if we change freshman orientation so that students are trained first and
foremost in how to step back,
give people the benefit of the doubt,
be open minded.
If we do that first,
you know,
that's like behavioral,
um,
exposure to some degree,
right?
The idea would be that if you're,
if you're afraid or by something that you don't understand the appropriate first
treatment,
first of all,
the treatment is necessary because otherwise the old,
you'll isolate yourself in the ways that you already described.
And second,
that brief exposure,
voluntary exposure is going to be the best curative.
Now it's the opposite of the safe space idea is that you need to be protected.
Safe space.
The safe space idea is the worst thing you could possibly do for the very people
you're trying.
Exactly,
exactly.
I mean the psychology,
what you know,
the psychology behind safe spaces and microaggressions is just the exact
opposite of what we should be doing.
If we want to create kids,
especially black kids,
gay kids,
we made whatever.
If you think that they are vulnerable to more stigma,
more conflict,
if you think that they are vulnerable,
that's especially when a safe space will be temporarily pleasant,
but in the long run bad course.
Right.
And that's the critical issue too with regards to safe spaces is that they're
sacrificing the medium and longterm of the students' wellbeing,
let's say to the short term,
lack of fear and conflict there.
Infant dialyzing them essentially.
So yeah.
Okay.
So all right,
so are,
I was thinking about the,
the discussion idea.
I've got a personality test online now that's based on this big five aspect
scale.
But it might be interesting as something for,
for us to think about too,
to find people who are high in openness and low in conscientiousness or
orderliness and offer them the opportunity to engage in dialogue with people who
have the opposite personality traits,
you know,
because,
well,
first of all,
because they're going to run into people like that always,
right?
And,
and,
and maybe even establish a relationship with them inadvertently.
And so being able to tolerate that might give them the kind of insight that you
said you developed when you realize that the conservative ethos was based on a
reasonable but not complete set of,
of,
of beneficial axiomatic presuppositions.
So.